THIS IS THE GREATEST COUNTRY ON
EARTH.
AMONG OUR NATURAL RESOURCES AN
ENDLESS SUPPLY OF IDIOTS, THEY
ARE EVERYWHERE.
YOU DON'T EVEN NEED TO FRAK
THEM.
HERE'S A WEEKS WORTH RIGHT HERE.
FIRST UP IS LIZ WARREN.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS CHIEF
SPREADING BOWL.
[LAUGHTER]
AFTER YEARS OF BEING ACCUSED OF
LYING OF HER NATIVE AMERICAN
BACKGROUND, SHE DECIDES TO TAKE
A DNA TEST, CREATING A VIDEO
WITH LAUGHABLE RESULTS.
>> THE PRESIDENT LIKES TO CALL
MY MOM A LIAR.
WHAT ARE DO THE FACTS SAY?
>> THE FACTS SUGGEST THAT YOU
HAVE NATIVE AMERICAN ANCESTRY IN
YOUR PEDIGREE.
>> GREG: WOW.
THAT LOOKED TOTALLY NATURAL.
SHE GOT ANY STIFFER I WOULD
CHECK FOR THE TOE TAG.
TALK ABOUT A PALEFACE.
IT'S TELLING THAT THEY CHOSE
SOME STANFORD ACADEMIC TO
CONNECT THESE TERRIBLE RESULTS,
THEY JUST KNEW THEY WERE ABOUT
TO PAINTED TURTLE ORANGE AND
CALL IT SHERBET.
WHEN THE RESULTS ARRIVED, IT
AMOUNTED TO SOMETHING BETWEEN
NEARLY ZERO AND NEARLY ZERO.
LIKE .09.
IF YOUR IQ WAS .09, YOU WOULD BE
GRANTED.
IF THEY GAVE HER A BREATHALYZER,
SHE WOULD BE OVER THE LEGAL
LIMIT OF STUPID.
AS A WISE MAN ONCE SAID, WHEN IT
COMES TO CHEROKEE, SHE HAS MORE
IN COMMON WITH THE JEEP.
MAYBE SHE COULD BE THERE
SPOKESMAN.
THE SLOGAN, UNLIKE ME THIS
CHEROKEE IS NOT FULLY -- SO,
THINK ABOUT WHAT SHE PULLED OFF.
ONE LAW SCHOOL DIRECTORY LISTED
HER AS NATIVE AMERICAN FOR NINE
YEARS.
HARVARD HAS HER AS NATIVE
AMERICAN UNTIL 2004.
SHE WAS CALLED THE HARVARD LAW
FIRST WOMAN OF COLOR.
THEN THE COOKBOOK.
POWWOW CHILD.
RECIPES FROM FIVE INDIAN TRIBES.
SHE LISTED HERSELF AS CHEROKEE.
YES AND I AM -- FROM ABBA.
[LAUGHTER]
ACTUALLY, I DID SOME RESEARCH TO
FIND OUT WHO HAS MORE NATIVE
AMERICAN BLOOD THAN HER, HERE
THEY ARE.
-- FROM ABBA ANNA FREED FROM
ABBA, AND THE OTHER GUY FROM
ABBA.
HARD TO BELIEVE.
I ACTUALLY DID MORE RESEARCH TO
FIND OUT WHO HAS MORE NATIVE
AMERICAN BLOOD THAN HER,
FLIPPER.
MY OFFICE STAPLER, THIS HELMET.
SO, WE SPENT A LONG TIME BEING
LECTURED BY LEFT-WING A HOLES
ABOUT WHAT NOT TO WEAR IN
HOLLOWING.
BETTER NOT WEAR SOMBRERO, AMIGO.
HANDS OFF THE HEADREST.
CULTURAL APPROPRIATION IS SO
EVIL.
BY ALL MEANS, THEY TOTALLY CLAIM
CULTURE AND EXPLOIT IT FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES.
HASN'T SHE COMMITTED THE BIGGEST
SIN EVER.
SHE STILL WHO THEY ARE.
I CAN TALK, I AM 2% NATIVE
AMERICAN.
IT'S TRUE.
THAT'S MORE INDIAN THAN SHE IS.
MEANING, I AM NATIVE AMERICAN.
I KNOW WHAT I'M GOING AS FOR
HALLOWEEN.
[LAUGHTER]
SO, COULD THIS BE THE END OF
IDENTITY POLITICS?
IF DNA TESTS REVEAL THAT YOU
CONTAIN THE SAME AMOUNT OF
OPPRESSIVE ANCESTRY THEN YOU ARE
OPPRESSED TOO.
IF EVERYONE'S A MINORITY, THE
NOBODY IS, EXCEPT ME.
AS YOU KNOW, I DID DO MY OWN DNA
TEST ON THE VIBE AND THEN I DID
A VIDEO.
>> HI, GREGG GOT FELT.
MY ANCESTRY IS INCREDIBLY RICH.
REMEMBER THE DONNER PARTY.
HE NEVER WENT HUNGRY.
I'M PROUD OF MY FAMILY'S ROOTS.
I DECIDED TO TAKE A DNA TEST ON
THE RESULTS WERE FASCINATING.
TURNS OUT ON 40% BRITISH AND
IRISH.
9% IBERIAN.
2% NATIVE AMERICAN, AND 20%
MINOTAUR.
IN 20% GIANT SEQUOIA.
ONE OF MY GRANDDAD HAD A THING
FOR TREES.
I'M 30% CENTAUR WHICH EXPLAINS
WHY IT'S HARD TO GET JEANS THAT
FIT.
AT THIS POINT, I KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE THINKING THAT ADDS UP TO
MORE THAN 100%.
HOW CAN THAT BE?
I WILL TELL YOU.
IT'S BECAUSE I AM THE GARGANTUAN
DOUBLE BEASTS THAT FEAST ON THE
SOULS OF THE DEAD.
I AM OF INFINITE MANIFESTATION.
FUELED BY -- THERE'S THE WRATH
OF MY MUTILATION AS I TEAR AT
THE WRATH OF YOUR NAKED COWERING
--
>> GOT FELT 2020,.
>> DON'T APPLAUD.
THAT MONSTROSITY.
THAT WAS REALLY UNEXPECTED.
THE OTHER IDIOT THIS WEEK, THE
LITIGATING LOLLIPOP, MICHAEL
EVAN EDDIE.
HE HAD BEEN USING VARIOUS
VICTIMS TO ATTRACT THE SPOTLIGHT
FOR HIMSELF.
WHEN HE FINALLY FINDS THE
SPOTLIGHT, THIS HAPPENS.
THIS WEEK THE JUDGE RULED IN
FAVOR OF DONALD TRUMP
INSTRUMENTS DEFAMATION CASE IN
ORDER THAT HE SHE PAY TRUMP
LEGAL FEES.
THAT'S THEIR WAY OF SAYING HER
LAWYERS GIVEN LAWYERS A BAD
NAME.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
SHE IS A PORN STAR AND HER
LAWYER SO BAD THAT SUDDENLY HER
CAREER LOOKS RESPECTABLE.
SHE USED TO GET PAID TO SCREW
PEOPLE, ABBA NETTING JUST
SCREWED HER AND SHE HAD TO PAY
HIM.
[LAUGHTER]
HE IS TO LAWYERS WHAT THEY ARE
TO INDIANS, AND EMBARRASSMENT.
IT HAS BEEN A WEEK OF
BACKFIRING.
EVERYTHING BLEW UP IN THEIR
FACES.
THE DNA TEST EXPOSES THEM AND
THEY EXPOSE HIM AS BOZO.
U.S. JOB OPENINGS HIT -- PRETTY
SOON YOU'RE GOING TO NEED A DNA
TEST TO PROVE THAT YOU ARE AN
UNEMPLOYED AMERICAN.
THAT'S PRETTY GOOD FOR TRUMP BUT
IT MAY NOT BE GOOD FOR LIZ
WARREN AND AVENATTI.
THERE MAY BE 7 MILLION JOB
OPENINGS BUT WE STILL HAVE AT
LEAST TWO MORE IDIOTS THAN WHAT
WE NEED.
[APPLAUSE]
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT GUEST.
PRESCRIPTION FOR YOUR
AFFLICTION, HOST OF DOCTOR DREW
MIDDAY LIVE, DOCTOR DREW PINSKY.
HE SPLIT MORE SIZE THAN A
BUTCHER ON METH.
JIMMY PHELAN.
>> SHE'S THE PINNACLE OF
CYNICAL, CAP TIM.
[APPLAUSE]
AND, HE ALWAYS HAS HIS HEADS IN
THE CLOUD, TYRUS.
>> DOCTOR DREW, YOU ARE A DR.,
WHAT DID SENATOR WARN
ACCIDENTALLY DUE TO HERSELF THIS
WEEK.
>> MY PROGRAM I'VE FOUND THAT I
HAD NATIVE AMERICAN CALL US AND
SAY THAT THEY EACH DID THEIR OWN
CHARACTER FOR HERITAGE.
FOR CHEROKEE IN PARTICULAR YOU
HAVE TO REGISTER WITH THE INDIAN
AFFAIRS DEPARTMENT.
YOU HAVE TO SHOW YOUR HERITAGE
BACK TO A GIVEN INDIVIDUAL TO
CALL YOURSELF CHEROKEE.
THEY WERE DEEPLY OFFENDED BY
THIS.
IT WAS THE ULTIMATE
APPROPRIATION.
>> SHE TRIED TO STEAL THEIR
IDENTITY.
IT'S AN OUTRAGE.
>> NOT AS OUTRAGEOUS AS THIS
JACKET.
>> THIS IS MY OLDEST GUY IN THE
BOY BAND, AND LOOKED LIKE THE
GUY THEY WON'T FIRE BECAUSE I
CAN BUY THEM BEER AFTER THE
SHOW.
THEY DO COME IN MEN'S.
I ACTUALLY DO THINK SHE
DISQUALIFIED HERSELF.
THE REASON I SAY THAT IS NOT
BECAUSE OF WHAT TRUMP WILL DO
BUT BECAUSE OF WHAT HER OWN
PARTY WILL DO IN THE PRIMARIES.
NOBODY IS TOUGHER ON YOU THAN
WHEN YOU SCRIPT AND YOUR
FRIENDS.
LIKE THE TIME YOU SAID YOU ARE
NATIVE AMERICAN.
SHE IS NEVER GOING TO LIVE THIS
DOWN FOR THE REST OF HER LIFE.
>> JOE BIDEN MUST BE PLEASED AS
PUNCH.
CAMILLA HARRIS, CORY BOOKER,
SHE'S GONE, I DON'T KNOW THAT
THERE'S ANY WAY SHE COULD.
>> SHE OUTED HERSELF AS DONE.
ANYONE WHO THOUGHT THIS WAS
ACCEPTABLE PROOF BASED ON THE
RESULTS, IT'S LIKE TELLING
SOMEONE YOU HAVE A HOT
GIRLFRIEND BUT THE ONLY PICTURE
IN YOUR WALLET IT IS CLEARLY
FROM A MAGAZINE.
>> I ONLY DID THAT ONCE.
KATZ, FOR YOUR BIRTHDAY YOU'RE
GOING TO BE SHOWING UP IN A
COFFIN.
THE YEAR LIKE THE LIFESTYLE OF
THE DAY, YOU'RE AS BAD AS SHE
IS.
>> I'M DEAD ON THE INSIDE.
SO, THIS STORY I WAS SITTING
AROUND MY APARTMENT EARLIER THIS
WEEK, SHOCKING I KNOW.
I WAS THINKING THE ONLY FRIEND
THAT I KNOW THAT LIVES CLOSE TO
ME ANYWHERE IN THE CITY IS A
CAT.
I WAKE UP AND THERE IS THE CATS.
IT DURING THE DAY THERE IS THE
CAT.
>> SO, IF LIZ WARREN IS
11024th NATIVE AMERICAN, I
HAVE TO BE AT LEAST 11000/24
CAP.
IF YOU DON'T THINK THAT CAP
HUMAN CULTURE IS THIS THING,
IT'S DEFINITELY A THING.
YOU WALK AROUND WITH CLOSE
COVERED IN IT.
WE BUY FROZEN MEALS.
WE OWN WINE STOPPERS, WHO ARE WE
KIDDING.
>> WISHFUL THINKING.
>> TYRUS, WHERE DO WE GO WITH
THIS?
>> I CHECKED OUT WHEN THE GREEN
DUDE SHOWED UP.
YOU HAVE LOST YOUR DAMN MIND.
THE.
>> GREG: ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT
--
>> DON'T START EATING PEOPLE.
>> GREG: I CAN SAY I PROBABLY
DID NOT WRITE THAT SOBER.
>> THIS IS WHAT THESE DAYS THAT
I AM SO HAPPY I DID NOT HAVE
GRANDPARENTS.
IT WAS HER LYING GRANDPARENTS
FORGOT HER IN THIS MESS.
YOUR GREAT-GRANDFATHER WAS A
CHIEF CHEROKEE INDIAN.
HOW MANY PEOPLE HEARD THAT LIKE
EVERYBODY SAYS THE SAME THING
AND JUST ONE.
MORE THAN TWO THEN YOU'RE OUT OF
THE GAME.
IT IS ALWAYS THAT ONE.
SHE BELIEVED WHATEVER WEIRD
NICKNAME SHE HAD FOR GRANDPA.
SO MUCH SO THAT HER TEAM WAS
LIKE THIS WAS NOT A GOOD IDEA.
MY GRANDFATHER TOLD ME, IT IS
TRUE.
NOW, WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH NOT
ONLY IS SHE NOT NATIVE AMERICAN
BUT I THINK SHE ALREADY KNEW
NOBODY MADE JOKES AND THERE IS
NO TEASING GOING ON, BUT NOW SHE
HAS TO FACE THE PRESIDENTS OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
EVERY TIME THEY ARE IN THE
HALLWAY HE'S GOING TO BE LIKE
HEY STOP GUARANTEED.
>> I WAS JUST THINKING WHOEVER
PUT THAT UP WAS THE SAME ONE WHO
PUT THAT VIDEO UP.
>> IT'S SATURDAY NIGHT AND RIGHT